good morning of the rules
committee for Thursday February
twenty first is hereby called
order of please be advised
an audio and video recording
of today's proceedings being
made as also being televised
amount of centrifuge call the
roll Cooley care Cunningham
Carillo him flora Grayson
Kamlager-Dove here Maienschein
Mathis their works over here
from monster reverse their
works here we have a fourth
we have a quorum and we
have a consent agenda is our
motion on the consent agenda
move I miss grow seconded by
ms comma tough -- matter sector
please call the roll Cooley high
Cooley aye Cunningham Cunningham
I. Carillo Carillo aye flora
flora I'd Grayson race and I
Kamlager-Dove Kamlager-Dove I
am Maienschein Maienschein aye
Mathis aye Mathis aye personal
phone works so well I Ramos
showed promise I read this
five reverse irix works
aye the motion is passed
and -- this rules committee
is a jerk thank you very much